oh hello hello hello hello
hi julian how are you
i'm good thank you it's uh it's really
early in the morning
so yeah that's that's good
soldiering on well let's get you back in
bed right after this
i am so excited though to talk to you
about godzilla vs
kong because i grew up watching both of
them so it was about time that they
co-star together
and speaking of co-stars millie bobby
brown
is your co-star on this and everybody's
crazy for her
but i heard that you guys had to recite
shakespeare together for a screen test
is this true
yeah so i remember we did a chemistry
read
we went into this office i thought okay
we want you to read the script
okay it's probably from the film and
then i look at it
and i'm like this looks like it was
written 300 years ago
by a 60 year old dude i don't know what
this is
um and it ended up being romeo and
juliet so
it was an experience but the story
obviously goes well because you get the
part and now you're in the movie
now i heard that you recently celebrated
not one
but two big milestones yes
yes i just turned 18. well not just but
i turned 18 like three months ago but i
just moved that home
i am currently yeah i'm chilling in
my own space i'm i'm independent i'm
living life
so well i have a quick question for you
i wanted to play a really quick game
with you
before we go to the break i was
wondering if we could kick up a notch
um and this is called before the break
[Music]
all right now we see tons of fighting
between godzilla and kong in the movie
but we were thinking like
i would love to get your take on who
would fare better in these
everyday situations you tell me
who would reign supreme and do better at
everyday situations like let's say
julian
attending a dinner party godzilla or
kong i feel like i would be godzilla
because
um he would just have better table
manners
he could also like flambe and like or
flambe
or like do a bananas fosters or some
crepes with his fire mouth
he could just be cooking the food he
could make the food and bring it to the
dinner table
exactly who would spare better in
speaking to the manager
i feel like kong because he can actually
um talk i feel like uh
godzilla would just yell at him so kong
yeah
babysitting babysitting mmm
godzilla because i feel like he's scared
he's like i see it babysat by my older
cousin
um and i hated it because she was
angry quite a lot of the time but it
really did kick me and my brother into
shape
so probably godzilla
meeting the parents
i feel like kong because kong could
actually um shake
the father's hand um because he has
hands
um yeah okay what about
being broken up with carl
godzilla would do like something
revengeful like go to
their house and burn every single
person they love to the ground all right
which one would you pick to star in a
romantic comedy
godzilla that'd be fun and why is that
can you imagine
well i'm pretty sure godzilla vs kong is
a romantic comedy to be honest if you
watch it in a certain way
it's a bromance comedy film that's what
i that's what that's what i describe it
as
then see the bromance of the decade
godzilla versus kong julian dennison
i'm so happy to make your acquaintance
it was an absolute pleasure
all right now get back in bed godzilla
vs kong is in theaters
today and on hbo max
you